turkey dinosaur america's original
rulers merciless
beasts grazing on the flesh of cowering
humans then in the 15th century
a vessel crashed two vessels really
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my full rick and morty season 5
episode 6 video
rick and morty blowing up everything you
ever thought you knew about world
history the history of america so there
are a whole bunch of easter eggs we'll
break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes
we're doing a giveaway for rick and
morty merch too all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave
your favorite easter egg or reference
from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet i'll just number these
as we go along talk about easter eggs
and wtf moments
starting with the title of the episode
rick and morty's thanks ploytation
spectacular so it was meant to be a
thanksgiving themed exploitation themed
episode that also parodies a lot of
typical tv holiday episodes
there were a lot of different movie
genres that they parodied like they did
a parody of national treasure with the
whole heist they did a big war movie
parody they even parodied
aliens in predator movies they even
literally
referenced the arnold schwarzenegger
predator movie at the end of the episode
it even felt like when they went full
nazi turkeys in space they started to do
some iron sky references
so just generally a mixture of a lot of
genre tropes and jokes from
different holiday movies and sci-fi
movies maybe even a little invasion of
the body snatchers with the turkey
president but the opening scene starts
with their straight up national treasure
parody with rick trying to steal the us
constitution because
like the plot of the national treasure
movie he thinks there's a secret map
on the back of the constitution that
will lead them to crypt of the new world
which rick thinks will contain this
grand treasure like the templars
treasure from the national treasure
movie
later they use that crypt to completely
rewrite the history of the united states
and the world in general when rick jokes
about the instructions for running a
country being online he's calling the
actual constitution
worthless because as he explains later
he hates all countries in the universe
indiscriminately
and the actual text of the us
constitution can be found online
he's also saying that any random person
could follow the instructions
and use them to be a president even
though most of the episode he spends
making fun of
keith david's president specifically
just because of their long-running feud
he uses the little rc car to soil the
pants of the minutemen statues just
showing even more general disregard for
the government
morty then promptly destroys the
constitution with rick's gun
which seems like a video game reference
so if you think you know what video game
gun this is based on
just write it below in the comments
because it does look kind of familiar
most of the time when they have really
cool guns they're based on something
from video games
while destroying the constitution the
beam also destroys the liberty bell way
off in philadelphia the beam then
continues to destroy the metal shell
around the statue of liberty
revealing that there's a hidden
steam-powered french assassin
that apparently the french intended to
use to conquer america back in the 1800s
which it seems like rick knew about this
whole time the way he talks about it
then when he jokes about thanksgiving
being america's birthday or
whatever it is that's just a joke about
how inconsistent
and inaccurate the origins of the
thanksgiving holiday are in the united
states
there's all kinds of historical
inaccuracies about the thanksgiving
holiday just in general
george washington in real life was the
president who turned thanksgiving into a
national holiday on november 26
1789 so that's why thanksgiving in the
united states has always been the last
thursday before december
it's another big episode with keith
davis president he's been in way more
episodes than usual during season five
he sends the military to arrest them
just reminding you that the president
has a bunch of super advanced weaponry
tech
in knowledge of rick's tactics like
they're using an anti-portal field to
prevent him from just portaling away
rika's also raised the blast shields on
the house a couple times this season
already
it is the thanksgiving holiday when the
events of this episode are happening
i don't know if they wrote it as a
thanksgiving themed episode thinking
that it might air
during actual thanksgiving in real life
or if they just wanted to do an
occasional holiday
themed episode and didn't really care
when adult swim was going to actually
release it during the year
they do that every once in a while but
like usually on television when people
do christmas themed episodes or holiday
themed episodes
they try to release the episode during
the actual holiday that it's themed
after
sometimes it doesn't always work out
like that though rick makes a whole
bunch of jokes about the president going
after terrorists and being kind of a
terrorist himself
you could think of it as a joke about
all of our presence for the last 20
years or so saying that the word
terrorist gets used so much that it's
lost
all meaning like you just go after
people that you don't like and call them
terrorists
the president then reveals that he has a
working phantom zone projector from the
superman movies and comics that works
the exact same way
so apparently the phantom zone is now
canon to the rick and morty multiverse
and it sounds like they actually have
access to real kryptonite when he makes
the joke about bars of soap and showers
inside the phantom zone prison that's
just the same super old joke that
everybody is told in their lifetime at
some point about not dropping the soap
in prison because
you know both summer and the vice
president make jokes about rick
and the president getting it on with
each other like why don't you two just
screw and get it over with
the vice president also calls rick his
space boyfriend
rick then implies that he's turned
himself into a turkey many times
before on many thanksgiving holidays in
many previous attempts
to get pardoned by the president for
crimes that he's committed in the past
is if somehow being pardoned as a turkey
would pardon him for human crimes that
he committed
when he yells at jerry to be careful
with his answer about how long he's
lived in the house
that's just a joke about him always
being gone on adventures
particularly when beth was growing up so
if he only counted the amount of time
he's physically occupied the house
it would be a very short amount of time
that he's lived there the whole
elaborate montage of him
explaining all these turkey missions
intercut with the president
deconstructing those missions and
countermeasures
is just meant to be another joke about
nicholas cage's heist explanation
montages during the national treasure
movies
this time the president plans to swap
the turkeys on the truck that rick'll be
on for marines who have also been turned
into turkey hybrids
most of you could probably recognize the
celebrity guest cameo this week the
marine leader cooper was being played by
timothy oliphant
most of you probably remember him from
the mandalorian season 2 recently just
last year where he guest starred as cobb
van
the person who gets boba fett's armor
after he went into the sarlacc
which boba fett then later reclaimed for
mando they said that the whole joke
about the human eye being face blind for
turkeys which they pay off later in the
episode after rick can't recognize which
turkey the president is
there's also another joke about that at
the end of the episode where the
bartender
can't seemingly tell the difference
between turkey president and the real
president calling himself racist
the president then makes the joke about
dwayne only being picked as vice
president because he needs 10 percent of
the white vote to win office
i guess you could think of that as
another obama biden joke maybe they
referenced the giant french statue of
liberty assassin
again and it's still in the process of
attacking new york but apparently the
president doesn't care about it right
now because it's new york and they'll
handle it themselves
i think that's a more recent reference
to new york handling its own emergencies
or doing things differently than other
u.s states during emergencies the last
couple of years
the new york state government actually
just kind of did the same thing a little
while ago last year with the whole vax
pass
thing they introduced timothy oliphant's
cooper character he and his midwestern
wife the other members of his squad are
just meant to be midwestern tropes
that's why they talk about being poor so
many times they speak with such
stereotypical
accents he makes very specific music
references for their demographic
then references a 30 mile radius like
they get really specific with their
jokes
which is just meant to be a generic
midwestern town then they reveal that
all the marines on his team all come
from the same area they literally live
on the same block right next to each
other they're all
super poor and they all have pregnant
wives or girlfriends
which they all kind of call out in the
parody song that they sing for this
episode
there are a couple different parody
songs that they made for this episode
rick and morty parody songs are usually
pretty good
cooper makes a doctor who reference when
talking about rick a long time ago dan
harmon when he was describing rick and
morty before season 1
used doctor who as an example the whole
plot with them turning the marines into
turkeys felt kind of like an
avatar movie parody with them becoming
the navi aliens
later when the turkey marines start
freaking out that's just a generic war
movie parody with things going off the
rails and some of them getting killed
like it's no big deal
they also kind of make it seem like
pardoning turkeys is one of the
most important jobs that this president
has they even have a hardcore
underground bunker beneath the white
house lawn for it at this point there
are so many secret rooms and caverns
and offices underneath the white house
you could call it its own city
the president figures out almost
immediately that rick and morty at the
house are just decoys that they've
trapped by a david blaine box
because rick would never be trapped by
something so dumb if you don't remember
the david blaine box joke that's a
reference to the time when magician
david blaine
spent 44 days trapped inside a glass box
it was really dumb at the time which is
what they're calling out here
two of the turkey marines are named
rodriguez and fincher i think those are
references to robert rodriguez and david
fincher the directors
robert rodriguez actually directed that
big boba fett episode during mandalorian
season 2
and he's actually directing a bunch on
the book of boba fett mandalorian
spin-off series this year
the book of boba fett is kind of like
mandalorian season 2.5
i will be doing full episode videos for
that but those episodes won't start till
christmas
at the end of this year and as for david
fincher there's also another david
fincher reference later in the episode
when the president yells fight club at
rick
jerry reminds us about his parents who
we haven't seen since the christmas
episode in season one anatomy park his
father was actually played by dana
carvey
maybe we'll see them eventually come
back to the show the president changes
himself into a turkey and it's the
second time that we've seen him change
his body for a mission
the whole thing with rake being afraid
of the president in turkey form is just
to make them feel more evenly matched
but the president makes a joke about
poor white people then ask cooper please
don't tell the 10
of your friends just another call back
to the joke about the vice president
and the white vote he also makes the
same 10 percent joke
later at the end of the episode as well
rick implies that the only reason the
united states is so powerful is because
he lives there
then they set up the whole post-credits
scene with the blueberries giving cooper
ptsd
and the turkey president swap with the
tracking chip and even though they play
this joke like it's a body swap sci-fi
horror movie
saying that because he got the
president's dna this turkey president is
now super smart turkeys as animals
are actually fairly intelligent compared
to other animals there's a whole bunch
of details about turkeys that they gave
you during the episode
like you could also call this the
episode with all the turkey facts
but the funny thing is that most of the
facts the turkey president quotes
are actually true in real life like they
joke about them sleeping in trees in the
wild and
flying in the wild those are both true
but the whole storyline with him winning
over congress with the pay raises every
couple of minutes is just a generic joke
about congress being totally useless
in all politicians being super corrupt
there's also an easter egg in the way
they use the camera here during this
scene too
when they're supersizing the turkeys
they pull this move called the dolly
zoom it's been used in a lot of famous
films so you've probably seen it
somewhere like alfred hitchcock's films
there's also the very famous shot from
jaws that everyone always points to when
describing this effect
originally it was just used to enhance
the emotions of scenes but in this
context the way they're using it is just
a joke referenced old school sci-fi
horror films
they reveal that all the turkeys who the
president doesn't pardon gets sent to
another secret cavern where they keep a
mutated version of fdr
who was turned into a giant spider
hybrid by a spider
version of the polio vaccine the
president explains that apparently
they use spider dna when making the
polio vaccine because their logic was
spiders walk more than anyone else
because of their eight legs
it's purposefully meant to be a very
dumb joke they make a lot of fdr
references to his polio obviously
because of the whole
vaccine joke morty makes a reference to
his fireside chats when he lights him on
fire
the president also makes a facebook joke
when he talks about how hard it is to
have an iconic presidency in the modern
era with the existence of social media
just because
politicians and public figures get
trashed so much online
whereas in real life when fdr was
president back then
it was actually fairly easy for the
government to hide his illness
while he was in office you could also
think of this feeding chamber in the
giant spider as a reference to sheila by
lord of the rings
the turkey president sells new york to
france i'm assuming that after
the real president killed him at the end
of the episode he canceled that deal
and took all the money back that he had
given to congress then they all just go
naked for a solid portion of the episode
and even the president goes naked for
even longer which i think is another
call back to season three
rick makes an inspector gadget reference
the turkey president then pays off the
terrorist joke again from the beginning
of the episode calling them terrorists
because he wants to get rid of them
then they reveal the president has a
secret motorcycle hidden inside the
congress chamber
activated by mary todd lincoln's name
she was abraham lincoln's wife
rick then reveals that he keeps spare
clothes for the president
at his house in that it's one of the
president's safe houses like he's used
it as a safe house before
he's only got spares for himself morty
and summer no spare clothes for beth or
jerry apparently
rick then clarifies the reason why he
hates all countries in the multiverse
is because they're only glorified job
placement programs for politicians that
invent
each country as if they're only invented
for the purposes of giving themselves
jobs
the president also starts taking shots
at morty left and right too but then is
put in his place by beth
who brings them all to thanksgiving
dinner and i like that the president is
somehow
almost as powerful as rick like he can
push rick around but he still cowers in
front of beth for some reason
and i love that he's still super duper
naked while this is happening and nobody
references at all nobody calls it out
like it's no big deal
they both make like they were almost
ready to run to the corner bar until
rick is like bar suck on thanksgiving we
can't do that
jerry is watching a wizard of oz remake
by charlie kaufman
and he typically does stories with
really bizarre plots that showcase
a sense of fantasy in the real world
which is why you hear dorothy talking
about
real vital organs in the scarecrow is
trying to write his own movie
inside the wizard of oz movie the
president then rips jerry revealing that
he hasn't paid any income tax in a long
time because he hasn't had a paying job
in a long time bonding with rick briefly
over their dislike of jerry
then when they start making all the nazi
jokes with the big super soldier turkey
plot
the nazi turkeys in space it kind of
made me think of the iron sky movie but
if you think you know another movie that
they're parroting here with the turkey
super soldiers just write it below in
the comments
summer makes a reference to genocide
talking about what the united states did
in real life to most native american
tribes over the course of its history
then the president reveals the true
secret behind the treasure that rick was
trying to steal at the beginning of the
episode
and in doing so the show basically
rewrites the entire history of the world
in america
it's actually a pretty big deal so we'll
see if they continue to reference the
true history of the world in future
episodes
but the whole idea is that instead of
the templar treasure that rick was
hoping for
america has secretly been keeping
ancient alien pilgrims and indians who
came to earth to share their technology
so every major advancement in innovation
in human history
is because of ancient aliens i think
that's just another joke about ancient
aliens building the pyramids and things
like that
real world conspiracy theories but
they're kind of doing this as an
aliens and predator movie parody like
these are aliens and these are predators
then like i said later at the end of the
episode one of the aliens literally
mentions the predator movie
like somehow while they were in
hibernation after coming to earth they
were also able to watch movies
they make a bunch of jokes about the
revolutionary war when rick says
training a bunch of hillbillies was
enough to beat the british
then they bring back cooper in his squad
or at least the ones that are still
alive
there's a joke about them not serving
presidents at the bar because at one
point in history jimmy carter left an
unpaid tab of 53 dollars
i think maybe in real life he was
criticized once for being frugal or not
tipping well or something like that
it felt like that was what they were
referencing with that jimmy carter joke
his whole rousing presidential speech is
meant to be a parody of all
rousing presidential speeches like
independence day with him just saying a
lot of nonsense then they make a joke
about star wars
atats and how fans argue over the
correct pronunciation
adat or atat the whole thing about them
calling it out is unlicensed just feels
like the show buffering itself like
please don't sue us lucasfilm
the entrance to the new crypt is inside
the lincoln memorial and then they
reveal that there were at one point
turkey dinosaurs
ruling over america before the aliens
came
the two vessels that crashed there were
the predator and alien pilgrims and
indians
and apparently they have the natural
mutant ability to raise
corn on command using the corn cobs to
kill the mutant turkeys they make a joke
about the low-level enlisted men that
are there
only being there so they can pay for
college in the united states
if you enlist in the army or in the
armed forces because of the gi bill the
government will pay for your college
the turkeys use the washington monument
as a giant humanizer ray which morty
then later destroys at the end of the
episode
and the funny thing is that rick says if
you destroy it we'll have to do this
again next year as if
they're gonna do another thanksgiving
themed episode or another holiday
episode next year
and they end the episode with it still
destroyed so it sounds like they will do
another holiday episode during season
six
the president officially pardons rick
meaning that he is now pardoned for
everything that he has ever done
up to this point sort of wiping his
slate clean i did think it was kind of
weird that the turkey president's plan
is to only supersize american turkeys
you'd think that he would want to do
that to all the turkeys on the planet
and apparently the mutant turkey
wishbones in the rick and morty
multiverse
actually grant real wishes then they
make a whole bunch of jokes about the
president being obsessed with
playstation consoles his whole life and
apparently maroon 5 for some reason
his life flashes before his eyes but
throughout history
amongst you know real world big wtf
events every other moment is basically
the release of a new playstation console
and he ends the flashback with him
yelling about wanting a playstation 5
which i feel like is just a joke about
nobody being able to actually buy a
playstation 5 this past year
the president kind of makes a racist
joke about the aliens saying that he
doesn't speak guga
he also called the aliens that were
infesting the tunnels beneath the white
house during season three gugaz
as if googa is the word that he uses for
all aliens and creatures
but then during the post-credits scene
they pay off that blueberries joke where
cooper gets ptsd from their mission and
starts acting like a turkey again
eating all the blueberries off the floor
in a frenzy also joking about how the
government just canceled his military
health insurance because they need more
money to build missiles
with overall it was a pretty ridiculous
holiday themed episode but if you
spotted any big easter eggs that i
didn't mention during the video just
write them below in the comments
my full rick and morty season 5 episode
7 video will post next week that's the
voltron episode the one that leaked
early a couple weeks ago so some of you
may have seen it already
i'll name a new giveaway winner when i
post that video right now everyone click
here to learn how iron man knew about
kang inside the mcu and click here for
all my rick and morty episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight